[Música]
es un placer estar con ustedes Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y les doy la bienvenida
Así es Asia el magazín quincenal de
France 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente Estos son
nuestros titulares
amnistía internacional y la comisión
internacional de juristas piden a la
Corte Penal Internacional investigar
como crímenes de lesa humanidad los
abusos de los que son víctimas las
mujeres y niñas por parte de los
talibanes en Afganistán el informe
señala que se trata de una persecución
basada en motivos de género
en India los accidentes industriales
Matan al año a miles de personas e
incapacitan por vida a otro tanto según
el gobierno al menos 6.500 trabajadores
murieron entre 2017 y 2021 Pero los
activistas denuncian que las cifras son
mayores
en este 2023 se cumplen 70 años de la
primera conquista del monte Everest
conoceremos Quiénes fueron los hombres
que lograron esta hazaña y que abrieron
camino para que miles de personas más se
aventuren en esta peligrosa travesía
iniciamos este recorrido por el
continente asiático en Afganistán y con
el reciente informe de amnistía
internacional y la comisión
internacional de juristas titulado la
guerra de los talibanes contra las
mujeres el crimen contra la humanidad de
la persecución de género en Afganistán
en el que se evidencian los graves
abusos y maltratos de los que son
víctimas las mujeres y niñas en él se
sugiere que la Corte Penal Internacional
debe incluir su investigación que se
trate de una campaña de persecución por
motivos de género ya que los talibanes
pretenden anularlas completamente de la
sociedad pues se les ha apartado de la
educación y de asumir cargos políticos y
empleos en el sector público trabajar en
ongs y la ONU entre otras restricciones
en pocas palabras se les trata como
ciudadanas de segunda clase
para profundizar en los pormenores de
este informe conectamos con Santiago
cantón secretario de la comisión
internacional de juristas que junto con
amnistía internacional realizaron este
reporte Santiago Muchas gracias por
aceptar esta invitación y comienzo
preguntándole Cuáles son esos criterios
que consideran ustedes que se cumplen
para que la Corte Penal Internacional
investigue como crímenes de lesa
humanidad lo que sucede en Afganistán
creo que es importante tener presente
muchas gracias por darle publicidad este
informe porque nos parece súper
importante tanto amnistía internacional
como a nosotros que se sepa lo que está
pasando en Afganistán para que la
comunidad internacional tome acciones
concretas y rápido qué es lo que estamos
viendo que desde que agosto del 2021
cuando el los talibanes tomaron kabul y
de hecho son el gobierno la
administración de facto
se comprometieron a respetar el derecho
de las mujeres y han hecho Exactamente
lo opuesto Y eso es lo que planteamos en
este informe con con información
bastante precisa de que lo que está
pasando para de ser muy breve las
mujeres no pueden salir a caminar por la
calle si no están siendo acompañadas por
un por un hombre insisto no pueden salir
de su casa si no están acompañadas por
un hombre no pueden trabajar la mayoría
de las mujeres particularmente en kabul
trabajaba en organismos internacionales
ongs internacionales Naciones Unidas y
se les ha prohibido trabajar en en esos
lugares no pueden estudiar pueden tener
una educación mínima muy mínima y por
supuesto hay otras cuestiones Como aún
peores como que son obligadas a casarse
inclusive cuando son menores de edad eso
es lo que hemos identificado que la
amnistía internacional y es unos
aspectos más graves que tiene
consecuencias aún peores que si quieren
podemos seguir hablando de eso también
Cuál es el cambio o la respuesta que
piden precisamente de la comunidad
internacional para frenar estos abusos
perfecto Qué es lo que está pasando en
base a eso a eso que mencioné antes de
las prohibiciones que tienen las mujeres
obviamente muchas mujeres se oponen a
eso y protestan cuál es la consecuencia
de esa protesta hay detenciones
arbitrarias o sea son son detenidas de
manera completamente arbitraria son
torturadas algunas algunas han
desaparecido eso es lo que hemos visto
en el informe por lo tanto consideramos
conjuntamente con amnistía internacional
que se dan los requisitos para que se
considere que se están cometiendo
crímenes de lesa humanidad por
persecución de género específicamente
por percusión de género y eso es lo que
estamos planteando y es lo que la Corte
Penal Internacional
ha escrito en un documento solo a fines
de diciembre del 2022 hace muy poco
donde explica con bastante detalle Qué
es la persecución de género y en ese
informe se plantean muchos los
parámetros que nosotros estamos viendo
en Afganistán por lo tanto una de las
primeras cosas que le pedimos a la
comedia internacional específicamente a
la Corte Penal Internacional es que
continúe avanzando la investigación que
abrió hace un tiempo y que la reinicie y
que profundice para poder llevar a la
justicia a todos los responsables por
estos crímenes de lesa humanidad
este tipo de investigaciones en la Corte
Penal Internacional cuánto tiempo pueden
tardar es decir es posible que veamos en
el corto o mediano plazo un fallo a
favor de las mujeres y niñas en
Afganistán
siempre es el gran problema
y la justicia internacional muchas veces
es muy lenta y esto lo hemos hablado
muchas veces
la Corte Penal Internacional la fiscalía
la Corte Penal Internacional inició una
investigación hace un tiempo de un
tiempo atrás luego debió suspenderla por
por motivos estrictamente técnicos
dentro de la Fiscalía de la Corte Penal
Internacional y ahora ya la puede
reiniciar esa investigación por lo tanto
esperemos que en los próximos meses se
reinicie Y luego vienen otras etapas que
es determinar Quiénes son los
responsables determinar En qué tipo de
delitos y llevarlos a juicio estamos
hablando de año no estamos hablando de
meses no pero ya de por sí el hecho de
que la corte la fiscalía de la Corte
Penal Internacional investigue y otros
países tomen acciones concretas que
pueden tomar hoy en día como iniciar
juicios internacionales en contra de
estas personas como pedirle a las
Naciones Unidas que haga una
investigación más específica todo eso le
puede poner límites con suerte a las
cosas que están pasando en ka hice un
apoyo muy importante para millones de
mujeres que hoy en día viven en una
situación completamente de violaciones
sistemáticas a sus derechos
agradecemos a Santiago cantón por haber
estado con nosotros en India los
accidentes industriales matan e
incapacitan a miles cada año entre 2017
y 2021 al menos 6.500 personas
fallecieron en el trabajo según
autoridades públicas muchos más según
activistas sindicales India aspira
convertirse en una potencia Industrial
que fomente la inversión y la innovación
pero las tragedias relacionadas con el
trabajo continúan siendo noticia en el
país
en Nueva delhis mailcan sigue de luto
por la muerte de su hermana a quien
perdió hace un año
Este es mi hermana murió en un incendio
estaba trabajando en una fábrica estas
fotos de cuando iba a la escuela estaba
modelando Cuando miro esta foto la
extraño mucho
el 14 de mayo de 2022 estalló un
incendio masivo en esta unidad de
fabricación electrónica en el oeste de
Nueva Delhi 27 personas perdieron la
vida y según testigos este edificio no
tenía salida de emergencia la única
entrada estaba bloqueada por cajas de
cartón Ismael atribuye toda la
responsabilidad de la catástrofe a los
dueños de la fábrica que operaba
ilegalmente
India siendo el país más poblado del
mundo se ha embarcado en una carrera
hacia el desarrollo industrial la
construcción de edificios y fábricas se
puede ver por todas partes las tragedias
como los incendios son muy comunes en el
país y los trabajadores pobres suelen
ser las principales víctimas
en las afueras de Nueva Delhi una
fábrica de piezas de grifos accedió a
abrirnos sus puertas su director y nos
mostró los alrededores
Esta es nuestra área de máquinas donde
fabricamos el Grifo Y los accesorios
en esta pequeña fábrica no hay salidas
de emergencia en extintores todas las
ventanas están bloqueadas por rejas de
hierro y basura a los trabajadores no se
les proporcionan guantes calzados de
seguridad
ni siquiera mascarillas cuando le
preguntamos a mujeres sobre la seguridad
de sus empleados él prefiere pasar la
responsabilidad al gobierno indio aquí
trabajan 17 trabajadores seis días a la
semana no se nos permitió pedir la
opinión de los trabajadores los
accidentes industriales matan y
deshabilitan a miles de trabajadores
cada año el Ministerio de trabajo de la
India informa un promedio de tres
muertes por día en los últimos años
mientras que las encuestas
independientes de 2017 indican que la
cifra es de 131
en la capital India una organización
internacional Está tratando de abogar
por estos trabajadores vulnerables a
purga caiguar secretaria Regional del
sindicato industrial denuncia las leyes
que podrían empeorar las condiciones de
trabajo
lo que sí pasa ahora es que hay un
movimiento por parte del gobierno se van
a detener las inspecciones aleatorias no
planificadas y no anunciadas Entonces
los inspectores informarán a la gerencia
cuando vendrán a inspeccionar esto no es
algo seguro para nadie ni para los
trabajadores
el gobierno ha anunciado entre otras
medidas que sólo las fábricas con más de
250 empleados estarían obligadas a tener
un comité de seguridad frente a los días
anteriores
una reforma también criticada por los
sindicatos
los tibetanos lo nombran frente del
cielo o madre del universo el Monte
Everest el pico montañoso más alto del
planeta fue conquistado hace 70 años
luego de numerosos intentos anteriores
suizos y franceses estuvieron cerca de
llegar a la cima desde 1921 pero fue en
mayo de 1953 cuando un experimentado
alpinista de Nueva Zelanda y un
habitante originario del Himalaya
lograron La hazaña el informe es de
Samuel Salgado
2 de julio de 1953 edmund hillary
alpinista neozelandés y ten sig norgai
habitante originario el jimalaya nepalí
conocido como sherpa son ovacionados en
las calles de katmandú
festejan lasaña de haber llegado a la
cima del mundo el pico del Everest por
primera vez en la historia de la
humanidad
semanas antes el 29 de mayo a las 11:30
de la mañana hillary norgay estaban en
La Cúspide de la montaña más alta del
planeta a sus pies
8.849 metros sobre el nivel del mar a
pesar de que estaba de pie en la cima
del mundo no fue el final de todo yo
seguía mirando más allá a otros retos
interesantes así describiría más tarde
el alpinista neozelandés su gesta en un
libro autobiográfico pero dominar el
Everest No fue fácil la invasión de la
entonces China de Mao se dunge al Tíbet
había restringido el acceso norte del
Everest y otros países que comparten la
cadena cariñosa como nepal endurecieron
sus políticas de ingreso al territorio
entrada a la década de 1950 además en
las gélidas y rocosas crestas del
Himalaya desaparecieron numerosos
alpinistas años anteriores golpe tras
golpe con regularidad desesperante una
Pedrera inestable dificultaba nuestro
ascenso y me obligaba a subir lentamente
hillary y el sherpan orgay ya lo Habían
intentado varias veces pero fue
justamente esa experiencia un factor
decisivo para triunfar en la aventura
que lograron 6.300 personas más en los
últimos 70 años
y para el cierre les dejo este dato en
China existe un carnet de puntos con el
que el gobierno ejerce control sobre los
ciudadanos es un sistema de puntos este
premio a los buenos comportamientos las
donaciones a organizaciones caritativas
beneficia con acceso a préstamos
bancarios y educación entre otros pero
también castiga si no se pagan las
deudas se contamina y se habla más del
gobierno este polémico sistema de
vigilancia se instauró en 2020 de esta
manera llegamos al final de esta edición
de Así es Asia recuerde que puede ver
esta y otros programas en nuestra página
web France 24.com y no olviden nuestra
cita quincenal
[Música]